Beurre ou margarine ?
Voici deux tartines êtes-vous capables
de reconnaître celle sur laquelle j'ai tartiné du beurre
et celle sur laquelle
j'ai tartiné de la margarine ?
Difficile de se prononcer.
La texture et la couleur sont identiques
et parfois même au goût on peut se tromper.
Et pourtant, ces deux aliments n'ont rien à voir.
Aller aujourd'hui dans Sur la planche,
j'étale ma science.
Je vous raconte l'histoire étonnante
de la margarine.
Première différence
entre le beurre et la margarine,
le beurre est un produit, autrement dit,
il est élaboré à partir d'un seul ingrédient.
Le lait, en l'occurrence.
La margarine, elle, est en revanche le résultat
d'une recette qui combine plusieurs ingrédients.
Très bien, je note !
Doucement, ce n'est pas la seule différence.
Le beurre est obtenu à partir de
matières grasses contenues dans le lait.
Il s'agit donc de matières
grasses animales.
La margarine est élaborée
à partir de matières grasses végétales,
de l'huile de colza ou de tournesol.
Enfin, aujourd'hui,
car ça n'a pas toujours été le cas.
La margarine est une invention 100% française
qui date du Second Empire.
En 1869, Napoléon 3, alors au pouvoir,
est à la recherche
d'un produit pour remplacer le beurre.
L'Empereur veut trouver une alternative
qui puisse mieux se conserver.
Il souhaite ainsi
fournir la marine française
qui part en expédition
pendant de longs mois,
ou encore les familles les plus modestes.
Un concours est lancé,
dont voici le lauréat.
Hippolyte Mège-Mouriès.
Alors ce nom ne vous dit rien.
A l'époque, il est connu
pour ses travaux  dans l'agroalimentaire,
en particulier  sur la fabrication du pain.
Napoléon 3 lui a même remis
la Légion d'honneur en 1861
pour l'ensemble
de ses contributions.
Et ça, ça compte pas pour du beurre.
Pour trouver un substitut au beurre, Mège-Mouriès commence
par étudier la composition du lait de vache.
Sur la base de ses observations,
il parvient à reproduire en laboratoire
une texture proche de celle du beurre.
Il utilise pour cela de la graisse
de bœuf clarifié, produit qu'il baptise
produit qu'il baptise
"margarine" du grec "margaron",
qui signifie perle
à cause de sa couleur nacré.
La margarine est née.
Je ne comprends pas.
Tu n'as pas dit que la margarine
se fabriquait à partir d'huile végétale ?
Minute papillon ! On ne met
pas la charrue avant les bœufs.
J'y viens justement.
Habitué depuis des décennies au beurre
et aux produits laitiers,
les Français sont perplexes.
L'Académie de médecine est même saisie
par le ministre de l'Intérieur
de l'époque pour savoir
si cet aliment est vraiment sain.
Ceux qui en font des caisses,
des tartines, sont surtout
les élus des départements de l'Ouest,
les premiers producteurs de beurre.
Ils ne voient pas d'un très bon oeil
l'arrivée sur le marché
d'un produit concurrent
et plus abordable que le beurre.
Résultat en 1897,
la margarine est tout bonnement
interdite à la commercialisation.
Allez, direction les archives.
Aux Pays-Bas, l'industriel
Simon Van den Bergh,
spécialisé dans le commerce du beurre,
parvient à mettre au point une recette
réalisée à partir d'huile végétale.
Très vite, les journaux vantent
le succès de la margarine,
que l'on baptise désormais
le beurre populaire.
Voici un extrait d'un article
paru dans un journal français :
Le Panthéon de l'industrie.
Monsieur van den Bergh,
commerçant hollandais,
fut un des premiers à voir dans l'invention
de monsieur Meije Mouriès,
l'application pratique
d'un problème dont il avait toujours
cherché la solution, tandis que d'autres
continuaient à attaquer
la margarine comme
une matière ant-hygiéniques,
préjugé qui a persisté longtemps
dans une grande partie du public,
mais que l'on peut considérer
aujourd'hui comme définitivement vaincu.
C'est donc là bas, aux Pays-Bas, que se développe
la margarine telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui.
Et si on essayait d'en fabriquer nous aussi ?
Pour fabriquer notre margarine maison,
il nous faut de l'huile végétale
tournesol, colza et de l'huile de coco.
Il nous faut également  de la poudre de moutarde,
un peu de citron et de jus de carotte.
On commence par mélanger les huiles.
Pour stabiliser le mélange,
on ajoute ensuite un émulsifiant,
un jaune d'œuf, par exemple,
comme quand on fait dans la mayonnaise
ou, comme ici, de la poudre de moutarde.
Quelques gouttes de jus de citron
pour la conservation.
Un peu de jus de carotte
pour la couleur.
Il faut maintenant refroidir brutalement
le mélange pour le fixer.
C'est l'étape de la cristallisation.
On le plonge dans un grand saladier
rempli de glaçons
et on continue de fouetter.
Et voilà, regardez le mélange,
s'est opacifié, il s'est cristallisé.
Notre margarine est prête.
Beurre, margarine,
c'est bon pour mon organisme ?
Eh bien, si les deux
produits se ressemblent,
leurs propriétés et leurs
intérêts nutritionnels sont différents.
Le beurre apporte
de la vitamine A à l'organisme.
La margarine, elle, est riche
en vitamine E et contient des oméga 3 et 6
qui sont naturellement présents
dans les huiles végétales
comme le colza et le tournesol.
Il s'agit d'acides gras essentiels
au bon fonctionnement de notre corps.
L'organisme ne peut pas les fabriquer.
C'est pour cette raison qu'ils doivent être apportés
régulièrement par l'alimentation.
De plus, les oméga 3 et 6
ont un effet reconnu
sur le maintien d'une
bonne santé cardiovasculaire.
Mais il est important
que le ratio soit équilibré.
L'idéal, c'est au maximum 5 fois plus
d'oméga 6 que d'oméga 3 au cours d'une journée.
Aujourd'hui, la margarine
peut parfaitement être utilisée
pour toutes vos préparations du quotidien,
qu'elles soient salées ou sucrées.
De la même manière qu'on utilise le beurre
et à performance égale.
il faut simplement veiller à ce que
la mention cuisson ou cuisine soit spécifiée sur l'emballage.
En effet, certaines margarine
aux promesses santé bien spécifiques
contiennent des nutriments
plus sensibles à la chaleur.
Bon, eh bien, il ne reste plus
qu'à aller préparer mes épinards.
Et cette fois, ce n'est pas du beurre
que je vais mettre dedans mais de la margarine.
Et vous, que cuisinez-vous avec la margarine ?
Indiquez-le-moi en commentaire
Bon appétit et à très bientôt les Épicurieux.